sherry's in allentown pennsylvania hi
sherry how are you
hi here dave christie thank you so much
for taking my phone call how are you
better than i deserve how can we help
yes i was calling because um my husband
and i we make 152 000 a year
we have and we're in baby step 2 so we
have 13 000
left for our cardinal and then i have a
42
000 irs bill that i pay 532
a month towards uh for 2020 to get out
taxes
and i got another 16 000 added to that
bill
but i did take the eye of the reset i
attended that and you set to identify
the big bad wolf
and for me that was the irs so i did
start this year the estimated tax
payments for them so i won't
have that issue anymore after 2020. so
you have a hundred thousand dollars in
irs debt
no no it is uh 42 60
okay i feel i feel a little better i'm
still can't breathe but i feel better
okay
yes okay yeah so 58 on the irs and 13 on
a car
all right i'm with you okay and i have
seven thousand dollars in the emergency
fund which i know it should only be a
thousand
so the reason why we have that is
because we're down to one car
but i've been able to work with that
because i see my clients
tell her or zoom and if i need to see
them when i have the card versus them
fridays
i use you know i'll use a car so that's
six thousand dollars
extra i want to know should i leave it
there
or should i put it towards that um
thirteen thousand to bring it down to
seven
which is a number i like a lot better or
should i put it
towards that new sixteen thousand dollar
irs bill to bring that down to ten
because i wasn't sure if the irs bill
should be in a category by itself in the
sense of
urgency to get rid of it when is this
was the 16
when is it to you is it from the filing
you're getting ready to do
from 2012 yes i filed and i owe 16 for
2020.
you've already filed yes
before you had to
um yes because i knew i was going to owe
because my husband when we looked at his
um w-2
they only took out 380 for the whole
year so we knew we were going to be kind
of messed up
i wanted to see how messed up i was
going to be and start planning today you
could have done it all and not filed it
though
um because you made the taxes do you
when you filed it they weren't they
weren't due until
it'd be next week anyway but oh geez
well your penalties and interest on that
16 are going to be mammoth i generally
put the irs at the top of the list
in this case i'd put the 16 irs at the
top of your debt snowball
and i would attack it with a vengeance
and let's get rid of it before it starts
getting
if you can get that cleared up within uh
90 days and you should be able to by
putting this six towards it
or seven towards it then then uh you get
that out of your life then we'll go and
knock out the car then we'll go and
knock out the last irs one because
you've got it on a payment plan
but you're getting hammered by these
people with penalties and with taxes so
we generally put the irs at the top
in this case i would put the 16 at the
top because as you said the urgency
yes okay i will do that now you have
corrected all of this
there's no more tax problems
and he told me exactly how much i need
to be putting away you know so for them
i did my first one in april
so they got paid i did my state in my
city all the time estimated they were
small but
i don't know that one scripture i love
the scriptures i wanted to give caesar
what two fees i felt they were getting
too much but then i don't
have to pay at the end of the year it
was like i'm doing now so well you don't
want to be penalized
you're going to be penalized if you
don't pay the proper amount of
and you're going to get hit with
interest on these as well when you don't
pay the proper amount
of uh quarterly estimates and you
haven't been doing it for a while
yes yeah so you're paying yeah this is
not about
this is more like if you want a
scripture be diligent to know the state
of your flocks and herds
which means get your act together that
means get your act together
you know you need to start paying the
proper taxes at the proper time
no more but no less
yes and that would be your scripture to
lean on
how does the payment plan work dave like
for the 40 for example you said there's
interest on that
if someone puts on if someone gets on a
payment plan because they don't have the
taxes the amount that's due
they can get on payment plan but there's
going to be fees yeah there's going to
be penalties
and interest and that 42 is just
horrendous i mean it's horrible
if you could get a credit card and pay
it off on a credit card you'd be better
off really wow
it's that bad wow and you don't want the
irs the kgb in your life
right they just have unlimited power man
to screw you up and so yeah you really
can't you know you're not gonna have
peace in your finances as long as you're
monkeying with those people
yeah so not only getting rid of the debt
but also getting the right amount of
taxes done
at the right time in the right way and
not depending on them to be competent
or kind because they generally are
neither
and i mean there's people that work
there that are occasionally but in
general the agency is not